Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier!
And welcome to Riddle School 3.
The next game in the series that I'm assuming is gonna take place in a school!
I dunno how to get that mouse out of there.
So you've just gotta live with it for now.
"Riddle High School."
Boy, that's a TINY little building, with some boarded up-
Whoo...
Wow, we get a whole intro and everything.
And some kickass music!
I like it.
Ok, is that a doo-
Oh, I thought it was a doobie.
Riddle School 3!
Welcome to Riddle School 3.
Nice little intro you did there.
Ah! This looks familiar.
Is that Mr. Sum?
How you doin'?
Oh, Mr. Soggy...
He's a generally lazy teacher who can be very strict if he wants to be.
Well does he wanna be right now?
Zack, he's always cooold.
He ran into the cafeteria burning a few days ago, all the flames were solid-frozen solid.
What? Yeah, that shouldn't be impossible.
That's Phred! Wait was his name spelled like that before?
Okay... lost his whistle...
Smiley... she doesn't blink,
I got a ruler.
Smiling globe...
Not make me happy. Peeling wallpaper - MOO!
World map! I don't know where the hell that is.
Air vent... chalk board...
I can't leave...
HOLY SHIT!
This is LOUD!
Oh, globe? Ahhh!
Chewing gum! It - that's good, right? What do I do with that? Do I combine it with the ruler?
OOH I DO! I dunno what that's gonna do but it's gonna do something!
Eh? Eh...Eah?! No?
Phred?! Zack? Smiley?!
Oh! How did - how did you get by the teacher to be able to do that?
He's sitting right there!
Ah... oh okay!
Oh! Ah!
Logical! I dunno - I dunno why, but okay. I'm totally down for that.
What the hell did I d-? Why?
Take that Mr. Soggy!
Douche!
Damn! That was some rubber band!
Oh. Now's my chance.
"I'm blind! I can't see!"
I'm just gonna panic and not actually look for my glasses! Which I'm going to take!
'Cause I'm an asshole apparently.
"That wasn't a very sharp idea, actually it was kinda blurry."
Very funny, I get it. Okay.
Alright then. Library- Oh.
Animated, yes?
Well then! Hello everybody!
*Librarian shushes Mark for closing a door*
I didn't do anything, I just walk into every room and instantly shout my name.
HELLO EVERYBODY!
Okay, this one's blue.
"How To Read. Read this. This *Laughs while reading* bu-hu-this par-was wroted by George!"
Oh! That's adorable!
I think I'm done reading now, and forever!
How 'bout dis one in pink?
Poem book! By Pinkee. Penny poem, Five penny-Find five pennies, find them all, every penny's in the hall.
RS3 secret, Don't beat this game two times straight or else you'll meet a certain fate.
Key, deep in the jungle you will find a key guarded by creatures that watch from the trees.
Monkey's? Okay, so do I need to beat the game twice in a row?
Huh, *high pitched* interesting! I might try that if I have enough time for it.
Face-on! Oh... apply directly to the toenail...that's not-that's not your toenail.
This message was payed for by Karsh.
Okay! What about this one? Zonic!
*Chuckles* Zonic is awesome!
I dunno about that. How are you Mr. Read? "I'm feeling kind of depressed. I'm a librarian and I can't even read!"
"Well, I can read, but only big-print books. You see, my eyesight is like a stuffed monkey doll..."Or whatever the hell I said.
How 'bout these? Someone else's glasses.*Gasps*   My god.
It's impossible!
Who knew glasses could work in such a way!
"It's a free bookmark."
Thank you. I feel like you would've given that to me even if I •didn't• give you the glasses.
But okay, I'll be on my way! Thank you sir.
Ooh, penny. They're all in the hall it said.
So that poem was probably correct.
So there are pennies in the hall-There's another one.
No. *Hums*
Women's room?
What?! Don't look at me like that!
What's wrong with that?!
What's wrong with th-Ey!
Come on don't judge me!
Alright, fine. Supply closet! Oh... stapler! No. Tissues? No. Trash can? No. Calculators? No. Scissors, rulers, Textbooks,  notepages, a dime..?
How 'bout, a bookmark? Oh, how 'bout I combine the bookmark? Ah..! It's a foot and a half!
Ah, it's genius!
Oh that's so smart!
I mean I'M so smart!
I'm the greatest! Yeah!
Hell yeah! I'm da best!
Alright.
"Where'd you come from?"
Uh, class I'd say and/or my mother.
Let's see...
Ahaha.
Oh, okay. "Which teacher did you just- "Oh sorry, I-I-I meant to read this! S-Sorry it was going on and I was just blanking out on there
Uh..."I came from Mr. Soggy."
"...Completely against coffee."?
"I remember when he told us his story about coffee."
"He spilled ten full mugs of coffee on his clothes in the first grade and everybody teased him."
"They called him "Coffee Sog" or something like that, and he hated that."
Didn't like the-
Wow, this is a story!
Okay! Bye then! Apparently. Okay, I don't think there was anything else going on there so I'm just gonna go through the rest of this place-If I need to come back to it I w-WHOA!
There's a second floor?!
Ah...So we get to have a whole bunch of flun. Flun. Flunnuwunnin.
Umwumwum.
Hello! Can I get some macaroni? Oh no, apparently not. Egg? Okay, never mind.
There's gotta be something else here. Ms. Munch.
Uh...Ah....
"I'd like some chocolate pudding?!" Okay, I don't wanna spend my money just yet.
You're fatter than the sun. Oh, you can live with that, you're proud of yourself.
Okay! So now I need to go upstairs! Because I checked around here. I see the-Oh! There's a layout, oh.
*Vibrato* H-h-h-hey! How you doin'? I'm gonna get you pudding, I just need a dollar to be able to do that. So.
Which one doesn't belong..? Okay... Weird.
How many pennies have I gotten so far? Three, so there's gotta be 2 more pennies-Oh, there's another one right there.
"Leaping from window PROHIBITED"
I don't think that I would be doing that,
but OK...
HELLO!
How are you doin' Mrs. Flask?
Are you okay?
"It needs a switch or a button to work"
"You need to make a button,  It doesn't have to be big. Slightly  larger than a pistachio nut."
Huaaah?
So it needs a swiiitch?
How do I get a switch?
I don't know, I got- I'm gonna explore the rest of the entire building first,
and then I'm gonna figure out exactly what I need
"Someone get me out of the locker"
"This is Richy, Help me out"
Give me money
What's the combination?
"I can never remember"
Well, How I'm supposed to HELP you?
"I have it written down"
"Mrs. Oddverb's Room"
"Tell her I need to get outta here"
Ok...
Alrighty then, little strange but ok.
HI again, oh that's my old friend.
Alright, bread crumbs and beaver spit...
Bathroom stinks...
Let's see, hallway's a mess...
Uhhhhh, ok doesn't want to clean...
I don't think he wants anything to do
WOOOO, wait there was a- shiny quarter underneath his...
*Markplier Noises*
I just want that underneath your butt, I want to get under your butt
is what I'm trying to say here. (kden)
Ok, so this is-ahh-and that's the last penny I believe anyway.
"B"
Okay, ooh, that one's different.
Ohhhhhh, nice and a nickel!
And a cone. Does it have a fish attached to it?
Ok, "Carrots are people too," I don't think soo..
The doors are locked and light out, she must be..
Oh, she's in the... lounge! Ah!
So if I go back to the lounge, will she actually want to talk with me?
Mmmmmmaybe?
HELLO!
Mrs. Oddverb... About Richy...
Uh...
I... I BEAT THE STUFFING OUT OF HIM!
Oh, you- you're happy about that, OK.
How 'bout...
Uh...
He's stuck in his locker...
"Again? Do you think I should go to my classroom and look for the combination?"
YES!
You definitely should!
Wow!
He actually listened!
Who would've thought about that?
"I should probably leave, too."
OK, BYE!
Have a good day ACTUALLY teaching school! That would be lovely...
"Chloro-Fill for $200, I need more money."
Yeah, I don't have enough money.
But Mark does... ;)
So, something behind anything over here? Nope... OH, there might be something over here in the cabinets!
Ooh! That looks slightly broken, maybe I can break it...
Nnnnnope! 'Whole lotta nothin'!
Blah blah, whole lotta d*ck there...
Nothin' there...
Maybe that drawer? Nope. How about this one-
AH! Got a nickel! Okay, so I'm getting closer,
but I need a lot more money if I'm gonna be able to get what I need.
But I got that nickel, so I'm good.
OK, so now if I go back upstairs,
the locker might be...
...
Wait, oh Mrs. Oddverb, that's right.
Hello!
"Found the combination to Richy's locker."
"Why the goat does it say 'BLOBBLES?'"
Alright, nothing else here. Okay!
Nothing else there... Alright.
BLOBBLES?
Uh...
*Confused Mark is very confused*
BLOBBLES...
Oh, maybe it's - maybe it's like 'boobies' when you put it into a calculator and you turn it upside-down.
You gotta- you gotta do it upside-down, so...
Haha! BLOBBLES! If you turn that upside-down, it's BLOBBLES!
YES! I'm smart!
Give me money! Give me money...
Phil Eggtree? Is that my name? I didn't know about that...
Ok!
Ah, yes, it was upside-down the whole time.
*sick coin flip*
Thanks, buddy!
Thanks, man!
"By the way, I'm collecting buttons."
Uh Mark
Are you okay
Someone get help
Oh god
Okay...
Oh wait, he's fine.
Thank you...
Rr- Alrighty then!
Ok, but at least I can go to- not Mrs. Flask- I can go downstairs...
...into the new classroom, and now that one's gonna be open, so hopefully there's gonna be something in there that I need.
Ms. Count!
WOOOOOOOW!!!!
*Mark is in awe of the monkeys*
*Ok Mark snap out of it*
Eeuuuuggghhhh...
Aaayyyaaaa...
How ironic that you hate monkeys...
Ok...
I got- I got the keyboard thing which might be able to turn on the um...button-making machine here.
How about a little bit of this action?
*( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)*
Ha-boinky? Is that gonna work?
*drum roll please*
Yay?
*ITS GONNA EXPLODE!!!!! RUN!!!!*
*RUN FOR YOUR LIVES!!!*
*Mark is very surprised*
*Wait a minute...*
Uh-oh...
*SCIENCE ROCKS*
Ah!
I'll take that...
Thank you!
"It's a start..."
You're a start! (What does that even mean?)
I'll take that and be on my way and sell it to Richy again wherever the hell he went off to...
Ok, whatever, you need pudding...
Is he in the janitor's closet for no reason?
Uh ok goodbye...
*You can do it, Mark! :)*
Ah, there he is, ok. Richy!
Hey, you want a button?
GIVE ME MONEY!!!
MONEY MONEY MONEEYY!
Yes, please... Thank you.
Money?
*I want money... ;(*
Aww, your last quarter? I need one more quarter!
*Mark is mad...*
I need one more quarter! How am I gonna get it?
I have no idea...
Oh, I haven't gone into the bathroom! Oh, I totally forgot about that!
Urinal, urinal, urinal, stall, toilet paper, I'll take that. Thank you very much!
I don't know why I neeeed it...
Maybe if I go...
...to the janitor, maybe he wants some toilet paper.
Ok, so the janitor said he could hear the plumbing but if the plumbing is ACTUALLY broken, then maybe...
*Mark will get it eventually.*
*Don't give up on him*
*YES YES MARK!!!*
*YEESSSS!*
Ah, there we go!
And flush it!
Flush it- YEAH! YEEAAAHHH! I'm doing it! I'm a smarty! I'm smart!
Look at me! Uh-oh, he heard it!
Uwah?!
WHAT'S THAT NOISE?!?
Ooooh, okaayyy...
Ah...
So he's gonna be there for a while,
and then I can get, HOPEFULLY, it's not just a dime underneath his butt, it was a quarter.
IT WAAASS!!
It was a quarter, ok, so now I can afford some... pudding...
*༼ つ ◕_◕ ༽つ*
If only I had $200...
Chocolate pudding, please, than k you very much!
Yes, count, it's enough!
Thank you, thank you! :)
Woah!
That is a... LOT of chocolate pudding!
Enough for a...
...big man upstairs. Alright. Gotchya covered, buddy!
*Mark is so polite!!! :D*
Let's see how quick you move for THIS one! C'mon bring it on! Oh gee! Oh geez! Oh! Oh okay! Oh-no!
*Indiana Jones theme plays*
Aaauuughh!
That's amazing! I love that!
*wall breakage*
Oh... oh okay.
Alright, what are we doin' down here?
Ah! That seems to be a problem! Thanks Chubb!
Really appreciate that, but I don't know why I needed to be in here.
Alright, so now in the office...
Mrs. Mooses!
"How can I help you?"
GIVE ME ALL YOUR MONEY
YOU HAVE ENOUGH MONEY MARK... jk
Ah... ok.
How 'bout... something else?
Insolent... Uh. Woah. What? Huh? Uh... wake him up!
I- I don't... see it. I- I don't know what I- I don't know what I pressed...
"Sent here to see Mrsrsrs. Potato..."
"I have a ruler with gum on it!"
Nope, never mind.
YOU'RE ALMOST THERE MARKIMOO
Potato... I'm awesome... WOAH! That worked?! I'M AWESOME?! IT WORKED!
The answer was that I was AWESOME, which I should've known...
Nice! Nice! Nice, dude! Take it!
It's all yours, buddy! Get outta here! You earned it! Congratulations! :D
Way to go! You're a champion! Awesome, man! You did it! Good job! Way to go! Awesome!
He did it...
And then I'm outta here, correct?
Yup! :D
Okay...?
So.
That's all I need right?
Badabing badaboom, I'm done!
Okay!
Is that everything?
Am I finally free?
YUP! XD
*Markimoo gasps*
I'm finally free.
I could've just wait- Again, I could've just waited 'til the end of the night and gone home...
On the school bus...
But that wouldn't have been as fun!
APPLAUSE FOR MARKIMOO!
WE ESCAPED FROM SCHOOL!!!
And we are free...
Aren't subtitlers awesome?
Not as awesome as Mark!
Oh! Do I have a car?
*high-pitched* Oh, I guess I'm in high school, so why not?
Nice...
Oh, I thought that was like a weed pipe or something.
*cue relaxing music*
Nice...
Aww...
Delightful!
And there you have it, the end of Riddle School 3!
A vast improvement over Riddle School 1 and 2!
Definitely more animation and more interesting puzzles and more coordination between the items, which I thought was really cool, so...
Thank you everybody so much for watching-
Actually, wait, hang on. It said... It said there might be something for beating it a se- Helloo...
Ah!
Oh, that's right! He said that he wouldn't get out until pigs fly, and thusly pigs are flying.
Aww, that's nice!
So I'm gonna, I- I might just blast through this game again to see if there's actually something...
BTW, no pigs were harmed in the making of this game.
...for me at the end of it, so...
That poor pig...
But anyway I'll see ya in a bit just in case I do. Or if there is something.
Ok, so I just got the key in record time, by the way. It was very, very quick to be able to do that...
Also... I don't think there's anything else that I need to do or anything like that, so I'm about to beat it for a second time, so if something's gonna happen, it's gonna happen now.
*in singing voice* I don't know how or why or when, or if it's gonna happen at all. Or if that thing was just a lie, but maybe- Woah.
*confused Mark*
What- uh-oh.
Uh-oh...
*A wild Monkey Doll appears...*
OHHHHH... HEEYYYYY!!!! WOOOAAHHH...
"You have been possessed by Monkey Doll?"
Uh-oh...
Oh, that's terrifying!
UHHHH that's horrifying!
*laughs* Oh god!
Oh geez!
Wow!
Ok!
Alright then, that was horrifying!
So that is the secret ending if you beat it twice in a row.
But that was actually pretty cool, I like that a lot.
It reminded me of Five Nights at Freddy's, but this was before Five Nights at Freddy's was even made, it was coooooll!!!!
So either way, thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always,
I will see YOU, IN THE NEXT video.
Buh-bye!